buondì allora cercato di mettermi nei
miei panni
uno viene arte è tutto contento poi ti
mettono a parlare dopo crociate trovesi
cioè per mons una sfiga pazzesca quindi
preparatevi al peggio
allora la prendo bene perché come come
potete vedere io sono un inguaribile
ottimista
uso questa slide da ormai sei anni cioè
da quando s'è cominciato a parlare di
crisi bicchieri mezzi pieni
ci siamo parodiata una famosa campagna
dell'economist e mi sono buttato
con questa cosa
anche perché io faccio un mestiere molto
molto strano molto complicato se non sei
ottimista sei morto perché tecnicamente
io da 30 anni di interrompo i film più
recentemente li interrompe il giornale
online piuttosto che i vostri telefonini
io sono un autore pubblicitario un
rompiscatole
come dire come primo approccio
addirittura non sono rompiscatole ma
esistono delle ricerche che dicono che
dopo i politici e giornalisti noi
veniamo giudicati i più grandi
contapalle quindi bisogna avere molto
ottimismo per fare questo mestiere
in realtà io non penso che sia così io
penso che questo mestiere che ripeto
faccio da ormai troppo tempo in questo
paese in particolare sul mestiere
importante perché noi ripeto noi
facciamo mestiere delicatissimo noi
lavoriamo facciamo cultura popolare e
lavoriamo quindi è su questo è la tac
del mio cervello che corrisponde a
quello di homer perosa ma è richiesto
anche un po di intelligenza perché noi
facciamo cose che ottengono degli
effetti collettivi
diciamo che c'è un grande bill bair ma
che è un grandissimo pubblicitario che
ha operato tra la fine degli anni
cinquanta nel 1960 fosse il padre di
tutti i grandi copywriter di quelli che
scrivono della pubblicità che diceva che
chi opera nei mass media da forma la
società può portarla in alto oppure può
farla scaraventarla nel fango
allora partendo da questo io in generale
anche quando mi occupavo di mozzarella o
di telefonini ho sempre cercato di
pensare al pubblico finale pensare che
era mia madre e mio padre i miei amici
il mio paese quindi cercavo di fare
delle cose che non facessero dei danni
in realtà adesso sta succedendo una cosa
drammatica che non abbiamo più nulla in
cui credere questo momento di
grandissima crisi istituzionale non
crediamo più nei partiti non crediamo
più nelle istituzioni non crediamo che
nella famiglia in molti casi nella
scuola perfino le rockstar e calciatori
che una volta erano punti di riferimento
almeno per la mia generazione pure loro
non è che sono dei punti di riferimento
forse negli ultimi gli ultimi tempi c'è
questo papa che è interessante è che
come dire che stiamo seguendo con grande
attenzione
non abbiamo più nulla in cui vede ma c'è
una certezza la gente è una certezza
cioè che la pubblicità far male alla
gente questo periodo hanno davanti
consumerismo la pubblicità non va bene
io invece sono convinto che la
pubblicità serba la pulita può dare una
mano a un paese soprattutto in un
momento di crisi la pubblicità alla con
molti colleghi la vediamo in questa
maniera la vediamo compunto una
creatività di un albero che fa foglie
poi i frutti poi fiori e poi frutti ma
soprattutto è uno strumento è utile lo
può impugnare lo puoi usare senza grandi
problemi
allora cosa succede che da un po di
tempo stiamo lavorando su questo
concetto di advertising civile c'è
qualcosa che nasca dal basso che non sia
solo commerciale che non sia solo
vendita ma che abbia una vera utilità
che serva a un paese servono nuovi
modelli quindi non serve più io ho
parlato di interruzioni dei firmano
l'internet shaun marketing come lo
chiamano gli americani non serve solo
interrompere entrare a casa vostra come
gli scarafaggi
e proporvi di comprare un giornale
piuttosto che una lavatrice serve
qualcosa di nuovo serve creare un
rapporto diverso
oggi vi porto tre esempi di questo
rapporto diverso in cui le aziende non
vendono soltanto qualcosa ma cercano di
usare i loro soldi per aiutare la gente
per esempio oggi vi voglio parlare di
mafie voi non lo sapete ma al di là
degli arresti eccellenti e dei sequestri
eccellenti 30 miliardi di beni
sequestrati alla mafia negli ultimi anni
case appartamenti ville aziende terreni
quasi tutti stanno andando in malora
perchè chi ha fatto i sequestri poi non
riutilizza pensate che 30 miliardi sono
dieci manovre sull'imu voglio dire non
sarebbe neanche male che fossero usati
meglio ecco pensate che addirittura
oltre a non avere una cultura della
legalità in questo paese si sta parlando
di clamorosamente si sta parlando di
evasione di sopravvivenza duro in un
paese per la rilevazione sopravvivenza
pensate a peppino impastato non so
quanti di voi lo conoscono non vi chiedo
di alzare le mani ma so che non tanti lo
conoscono è stato ucciso 35 anni fa da
suo zio tano badalamenti perché perché
lui era un giornalista era un poeta e
combatteva la mafia anche se era suo zio
allora questa persona è morta e 35 anni
fa da una decina d'anni non se ne parla
assolutamente più e noi abbiamo fatto
un'operazione un po strana abbiamo preso
un azienda di giovani trentenni che
produce occhiali per cui già facevamo
degli annunci un po buffi aggressivi
questo per esempio è uscito il primo
marzo dell'anno scorso ma i tre
ratzinger andava in pensione e noi lo
vedevamo come un bruce springsteen che
non va in pensione ma se ne va a suonare
con gli amici piuttosto che immagini di
capovolgimento del ruolo sociale in
questo caso lui che passa
l'aspirapolvere dietro ai comandi le
quindi un'azienda che già faceva delle
cose un po strane un po particolari
ecco hanno loro abbiamo proposto di fare
questo spot istituzionale non di vendita
su peppino impastato
se si insegnasse la bellezza alla gente
la si fornirebbe di un'arma contro la
paura lo merlo carta all'esistenza di
orrendi palazzi ci si abitua
ogni cosa pare che debba essere così da
sempre e per sempre
insegniamo la bellezza la gente così non
avremo più abitudine rassegnazione ma
sempre vivi di curiosità stupore non
conta quello che vedi ma come lo vedi vs
a utilissimi questo spot è andato in
onda su mtv dal 10 di dicembre al 30
dicembre dell'anno scorso è stato
supportato anche da una campagna di pr
abbiamo mandato questo film e il suo
comunicato stampa molti giornalisti
italiani in questo per esempio è il
prestigioso domenicale del 24 ore uno
dei pochissimi inserti di cultura di
questo paese dove addirittura anche qui
è stata riportata la notizia
diciamo che siamo riusciti su un
pubblico molto giovane con un
investimento molto piccolo a creare
sensibilità ma la cosa divertente è che
poi è scoppiato un grande caso cioè
repubblica ha pubblicato questo pezzo
sia sulla carta dei sudditi in cui si
parlava dell'ira della famiglia che non
si era sentita consultata per fare
questo spot
la cosa divertente è che improvvisamente
si è aperta una discussione ancora più
ampia di quella che noi immaginavamo
siamo finiti su tutti i telegiornali vi
faccio vedere questo pezzettino di due
giornale ma non è sulla bellezza scritte
da peppino impastato ucciso da cosa
nostra all'esistenza di orrendi palazzi
ci si abitua insegniamo la bellezza la
gente la famiglia non ci sta la bellezza
per peppino era impegno civile non
marketing il fratello giovanni chiede il
ritiro dello spot mentre chi lo ha
pensato si difende così ci dispiace che
la famiglia impastato pensi che abbiamo
voluto usarlo come testimoniano in
realtà come gandhi mandela oger che
abbiamo usato i suoi concetti per
diffonderli alla gente di fonderia gli
italiani in un momento molto importante
allora immaginate decine e decine di
telegiornali decine di trasmissioni che
vengo invitato io viene evitato giovanni
impastato il fratello ancora vivente la
cosa fantastica è che ci ritroviamo nei
cento giorni a andare in televisione
finire sui giornali che improvvisamente
si parla di peppino impastato la rai
passa in due mesi due volte i cento
passi erano cinque anni che non lo
mandava in onda la cosa più meravigliosa
per quanto ci riguarda è zingaretti a
sanremo il venerdì di sanremo quindi la
serata da 9 milioni di ascolto racconta
queste cose che non faccio lì non sono
qui per parlare di bellezza o meglio per
parlare di quello che un ragazzo pensava
della bellezza il ragazzo era peppino
impastato era nato a cinisi
applausi 35 mai parlato ci misi vicino
palermo
era un attivista politico poeta
giornalista la mafia lo uccise quando
aveva 30 anni nel 1978
non mi faccio vedere tutto ma quello che
vi dico che poi alla fine di questi 100
giorni al 7 di marzo perché ci parlavamo
con la famiglia ci parlavamo con
giovanni impastato andiamo a fare un
convegno su peppino l'icona è la realtà
che viene ripresa da tutti i giornali e
dove la famiglia impastato decide di
usare lo spot della polemica e come
scrive salvo palazzolo di repubblica lo
fa diventare lo sport dell'antimafia
cioè in questo momento la famiglia
impastato usa questo spot con un finale
diverso come spot dell'antimafia
ditemi se questo non è un nuovo modello
di advertising civile ditemi se questo
non è stato utile vi dico solo che tutto
quello che è stato fatto 40 milioni di
persone sono state esposte in 100 giorni
dopo dieci anni in cui nelle istituzioni
nei magistrati dell'antimafia nei
giornali nei telegiornali hanno mai
parlato di quello che tecnicamente è un
eroe dell'antimafia morto per combattere
suo zio
un altro esempio di advertising civile
rapido veloce
oggi mi sono messo la maglietta italia
perché parlo di questo paese ma anche
perché io adoro il basket ho la fortuna
di avere uno dei clienti assieme a
qualcuno che in platea in questo momento
pallacanestro varese che un club
importante di cinque club più importanti
d'europa per storia che ha come sponsor
di maglia un'azienda farmaceutica di cui
non faccio il nome ovviamente che si
occupa di farmaci equivalenti
ecco con questa società sportiva e con
questa azienda farmaceutica abbiamo
voluto affrontare un tema fondamentale
quello della donazione della cultura
della donazione in italia non c'è
cultura della donazione
vi faccio solo un esempio per il midollo
osseo germania 80 milioni di persone 4
milioni di donatori donatori italia 60
milioni di persone meno di 500 mila
donatori
parliamo di trapianti parliamo donazione
di organi 2000 e trapianti all'anno ce
ne sono 8 mila in lista d'attesa spesso
la gente muore perché non si trovano
non parliamo delle sacche di sangue
perché vi sto parlando di questo perché
assieme a pallacanestro varese al suo
sponsor di maglia
lanciamo un'operazione gratuita pagata
dal cliente società sportiva che è una
vera istituzione non i medici non il
ministero della sanità non le asl una
società sportiva è un'azienda
farmaceutica lanciano questa campagna
dove la parte della passione sportiva
del cuore si mescola con questo key
visual nel cervello della coscienza
civile e lanciamo una grande campagna
tifoso immortale in cui chiediamo alla
gente 5.000 persone di media al
palazzetto a varese decine di migliaia
di persone che praticano sport centinaia
di giornalisti che in provincia di
varese non è un fatto nazionale lanciano
questa operazione in tre settimane
facciamo più tessere quindi più donatori
che in tutto l'anno tutte e tre le
associazioni
scusate questo e bertesi incivile la
pubblicità che fa bene non era provvista
che fa male pagata da aziende non è che
stiamo facendo cose così terzo modello
qui stiamo parlando di nascere dal basso
letteralmente vi sto parlando di un
piccolo paese del sud dell'italia
sogliano cavour 4 mila abitanti un
assessore alle pari opportunità di 29
anni con un figlio disoccupato e un
altro figlio in arrivo senza budget mi
chiama mi ha conosciuto sette anni fa
esattamente in una situazione come
questa in un incontro pubblico un
convegno e mi dice io non ha un euro
come facciamo
voglio fare una campagna in questo paese
ve lo faccio vedere questa la piazza del
paese
sogliano cavour è un piccolo orribile
per noi siamo qua paese del sud abitato
da questo tipo di persone quindi
immaginate la cultura maschilista che si
manifesta in questa maniera non ci sono
soldi
come faccio mi dici mi dai una mano 2.0
io non l'ho mai vista
maria grazia manco le suggerisco di
prendere come punto di riferimento
l'immaginario televisivo csi alla scena
del crimine e le dico facciamo una
campagna che costi pochissimo che costa
100 euro per stampare questi bellissimi
nastri di scotch con scritto
riprendiamoci la scena del
delitto e lei con tre amiche comincia a
fare queste operazioni di comunicazione
qui non c'è neanche un azienda alle
spalle veramente una cosa che ci siamo
fatti da soli
cominciano a mettere questo scotch nei
punti in cui le donne da sole non
possono andare o appunto nei bar dove le
donne vengono osservate in una maniera
molto particolare piuttosto che alle
fermate dei pullman dove dopo una certa
ora non si può andare piuttosto che
questo sempre bar visto da questa parte
al centro anziani piuttosto che sulle
banchine vicino alla piazza
cioè è così che si fa advertising civile
questo lo dedico maria grazia che ha
avuto anche il coraggio di prendere lo
scotch e portarlo in consiglio comunale
dove lei l'unica donna immaginatevi le
reazioni la cosa fantastica di questa
operazione e che ovviamente si
appiccicavano questi poste rini dove si
spiegava perché si faceva questa cosa e
soprattutto lei è diventata una piccola
diva senza soldi a una rassegna stampa
alta così solo in puglia grande come
l'elenco del telefono di milano siamo
riusciti a dimostrare che se parte dal
basso ossia se c'è la voglia il
desiderio reale di cambiare le culture
le cose si possono fare perfino in
questo strano paese dove i telegionali
sono pieni di dichiarazioni contro la
violenza sulle donne poi di fisico un
ricordo di aver visto niente
il bello di questa cosa e che sta per
diventare un'operazione che stiamo
offrendo a 100 comuni perché al 7 di
mara 10 marzo
siamo stati premiati a venezia immagini
amiche e questa operazione sta
diventando un operazione pilota con poco
meno di 500 euro qualunque comune
qualunque associazione femminile anche
solo tre amiche possono fare questo tipo
di attività guidate da professionisti
che danno una mano
allora dove stiamo andando a finire se
ne andò a finire all ci vuole coraggio
io so che in questa stanza ci sono
cittadini ci sono imprenditori
immagino ci sia anche qualche politico
voglio bene a tutti però qui ci vuole
coraggio questo è un paese dove non c'è
più denaro per fare attività reali
importanti ma dove bisogna fare le
attività importanti per questo invito
tutti a cominciare a pensare una maniera
diversa
non si può rinunciare ad essere creativi
perché non si può rinunciare ad essere
umani quindi piantiamola di un
alimentarci del fatto che il patto
sociale non funziona che noi paghiamo le
tasse ma non abbiamo niente in cambio
cominciamo a pensare come aziende come
cittadini come esseri umani che si può
fare qualcosa e soprattutto che possiamo
avere tutte le idee del mondo possiamo
avere tutte le condizioni del mondo ma
non conta quello che si pensa ma conta
solo quello che facciamo e questo come
dire sono venuto questo tag per dirgli
che questo è il centro della questione
che la pala con cui dobbiamo zappare
deve essere anche questa cosa
straordinaria che ci nasce da dentro
perché ripeto la maniera migliore di
prevedere il futuro e crearlo
e credo che la responsabilità di quello
che succede in questo paese e me la
metto questa maglietta con grande
orgoglio nonostante ne parli male quello
che succede questo paese lo decidiamo
noi
grazie
un po banalmente ho preso la penultima
slide ma io ci sono molto legato e la
mia lucina su questo albero è ripetere
non conta quanto idea ma quante ne
riesce a realizzare ed è un augurio per
tutti noi